have you ever wished there were a
magical way to easily remember foreign
language words and phrases with little
effort nowadays many language Learners
claim that there is such a way thanks to
a flashcard app called Anki Anki claims
to make remembering things easy and help
you study less learn more and do all
that a lot more efficiently than you
would with traditional memorization
method despite anki's widespread
popularity many people are shocked when
I tell them that I do not use Anki in
fact I do not recommend it at all and in
this video I'm going to tell you why hi
I'm Lucario I'm a Language Coach who
speaks 14 languages and on this channel
I help people learn foreign languages
faster more efficiently and in a fun way
in this video I'll share five reasons
why you should not use Anki to learn a
foreign language words
before we dive into the reasons why you
should not use Anki I want to First give
you a little bit more information about
exactly what Anki is and why it claims
to be so effective at helping you
memorize words the story starts believe
it or not with a 19th century German
psychologist named Herman ebbinghaus
ebbinghaus was fascinated by the human
memory in particular he wanted to
understand how learning and forgetting
play a role in the memorization process
so ebbinghaus devised an experiment he
would attempt to learn a set of
completely new information and then test
his ability to recall learned items over
time to make sure he could not rely on
existing knowledge emminghouse decided
to learn nonsense syllables three letter
chunks of sound that had no significance
in his native German he would make long
lists of these syllables for example
with zof Taz Bach and Leff learn them
and then document a journey towards
reciting each list perfectly from memory
crucially ebbinghaus tracked a number of
important variables in the process
including number of repetitions time
between repetitions and number of
syllables and so on and so forth these
experiments revealed to Heming house
something that we now call the
forgetting curve the curve is a graph
that reveals the rate at which
information is forgotten over time
through ebbinghaus work we know that
information that is not reviewed is
forgotten quickly but information that
is reviewed or repeated shortly before
it is forgotten gets a boost in your
memory this reviewed memory will then be
forgotten at a slower rate than it was
before if additional reviews are
completed this rate of forgetting will
slow further and further until we can
consider the piece of information
effectively memorized the forgetting
curve reveals that the timing of
repetitions can be hugely important for
long-term memorization it even leaves an
enticing mystery if we knew exactly when
we were about to forget a piece of
information couldn't we then determine
when to review it for maximum retention
power that mystery is exactly why
software programs like Anki exist these
programs called spaced repetition
systems use data and algorithms to
supposedly pinpoint the ideal time to
review a learned piece of information
following that logic if you learn with
such software you would then be
memorizing information in the most
efficient way because you're relying
your review sessions with your brains
natural forgetting curve
here's the thing I have no gripes with
ebbinghaus or his forgetting curve I'm
actually a huge fan of the concept of
space repetition and I use it all the
time in my learning what I do not do
though is use space repetition software
I do not use Anki memorize super memo or
anything like it I never have actually
to be fair I have given Anki a shot I
have towed with it for a while to make
this exact video and now I know I will
never use it for my language learning
why well I've got five reasons why which
are one making flashcards waste learning
time two adding new cards can become an
addiction
three reviewing old cards can become a
chore
four flash cards take language out of
context and finally number five brain
friendly learning strategies make SRS
apps irrelevant let's Dive Right In One
Making flashcards waste learning time
one of the hardest parts about learning
a language an adult is finding the time
to get it done the demands of work in
Family Life often leave us precious few
hours to devote to our target language
for that reason I strive to spend most
of what language learning time I have
actually absorbing and using the
language in a natural way by reading
authentic texts listening to authentic
podcasts watching authentic films and
having authentic conversations with
natives if I were to inject Anki into my
language learning practice I'd have to
devote a chunk of that time to
inauthentic tasks most of which boil
down to tedious data entry in fact to
create a good quality Anki card you need
to do a bunch of things for example type
in what goes on the front of the card
type in what goes on the back of the
card add an image file if for example
you can find one
add an audio file again if you can find
it
decide what other information you want
to include like for example tags
formatting and different card formats
save the card
that's at least several minutes of work
and only just for one card if you're
creating a deck of tens or hundreds or
even thousands of cards as some people
do that's a lot of time lost even if
Anki does help speed up your
memorization process on the other side
that's a huge amount of time spent up
front just creating and managing your
flashcards and that's if everything goes
well from what I've been told Anki isn't
the simplest and most functional piece
of software so you'll probably lose even
more time just figuring out how to get
everything working the way you want
not all worth it in my opinion save that
time and apply it directly to using and
absorbing your target language two
adding new cards can become an addiction
despite the work that it takes to put
together a good deck of flashcards using
Anki a lot of that setup is front loaded
once you've planned the structure of the
deck configure the layout of individual
flashcards and then added enough cars to
get it started growing the deck actually
becomes pretty easy assuming you know
where all of your cart data is coming
from adding a new card can take anywhere
from a couple seconds to a minute and
while the ability to quickly add new
cards might seem like a good thing and
often is it is something that can
quickly become addicting the whole value
proposition of Anki is that it can help
you remember anything you want since
Anki flashcards are entirely digital
this actually seems visible nowadays
modern smartphones make it trivial to
carry car decks containing thousands of
cards or more anywhere you go
essentially Anki removes nearly all
costs associated with adding new
flashcards to your car deck assuming you
have the time to make the additions
there's nothing else preventing you from
adding every phrase you hear in your
target language right to your virtual
memory bank there's even software out
there that can make the simple process
even easier using programs like Subs to
SRS and voracious you can turn an entire
movie or television show into an Anki
deck of thousands of cars in just a few
clicks of a button you might wonder what
I'm complaining about here certainly
having a fast way to turn movies and TV
shows into learning material is a good
thing right yes of course it is but if
you do not know how to do all this in
moderation the size of your Anki decks
can quickly spiral out of control this
is because once you've got a deck of
Anki cards you need to actually learn
them and review them this incidentally
brings me to my next point three
reviewing old cars can become a chore if
you recall my explanation of the
forgetting curve you'll remember that
each time you learn or review something
there's an ideal point at which you
should review it again this helps you
strengthen the memory and slow the speed
at which you will forget it in the
future as a software program anki's job
is to show you a piece of information a
flash card and then algorithmically
determine when that next ID overview
should occur so for example it might
show you a card for the first time and
test you on its contents based on that
result it could then decide that you
need to review it again in a few hours
or in a few days when it comes time for
you to actually do that review Anki will
show the car to you automatically you do
not need to do any extra work this is
fine for one card but as you go through
and learn dozens of hundreds of cards
these reviews will start to pile up
before you know it you could be spending
more than an hour each day going through
your Anki reviews and that's before you
even get to learning new cards for that
day and if that sounds bad then you
shouldn't even think about taking a day
off because while you're taking your
break because you're busy sick or just
unwilling to review that day your anchor
reviews are still piling up when you
come back to Anki assuming you will
which is not guaranteed you'll have a
mountain of reviews to work through and
that's a terrible thing for motivation
people first become addicted to adding
new cards but then become opposed to
actually reviewing them this becomes a
vicious circle which ultimately causes
Learners to feel overwhelmed and give up
their language learning I've seen it
time and time again and it's not good
for anyone
the tools you use should not only
motivate you to learn but help you stay
on the learning path for as long as
possible Anki doesn't seem to do that
for the vast majority of people which is
a major reason why I do not recommend it
but I'm not done yet let's move on to
the next reason 4. flashcards take
language out of context my next gripe
against donkey is one that I have
against flash cards in general by
definition they removed the language
you're learning from its natural context
think about it when you picture a flash
card in your head what do you see a
simple card with a word or phrase in
your target language on one side and the
equivalent expression in your native
language on the back
for all its bells and whistles Anki
boils down to just that a way to take
foreign language content and Shop it up
into small isolated pieces so that each
piece can be absorbed reviewed and
tested individually breaking down a lot
of information into small chunks is a
great way to learn in general but it
goes against how language inherently
Works language is not just a series of
isolated words and phrases placed neatly
next to each other in a row like so many
beads on a string rather language
functions as a network each word in the
phrase each phrase in a sentence and
each sentence in a paragraph or
utterance serves to reinforce everything
else around it if you remove any of
those things from its Network the
natural context that it finds itself
within it begins to lose meaning in fact
the loss of meaning can become so great
that in many cases when you remove a
word from its surrounding context it
becomes essentially meaningless you see
this practically anytime you look up a
word in a dictionary most words you know
have have more than one meaning but to
determine which meaning is actually
being used in a given situation you have
to look at the surrounding context to
give you a quick example think of the
word light on its own light could mean
the visible radiation coming from the
Sun or the relative weight of an object
but if you put just light on one side of
a flash card you have no idea which of
those kinds of light was intended at
least not without more context however
if you have never heard of the word
light before and I showed you a video
about the sun you quickly learn one
meaning of light and automatically
connect it to dozens of words and
phrases which can give you context for
that meaning like sun star solar system
radiation wavelength and more there are
ways to mitigate the loss of context
that comes with taking target language
content and putting it on flashcards
however that generally requires you to
squeeze more information onto each flash
card which can then make the whole
flashcard creation more laborious as I
explored in my first point given the
issues that come along with creating and
managing flashcards with Anki wouldn't
it be great if we could get all of the
benefits of space repetition but without
the extra hassle we came which is why my
next point I can say that five brain
friendly learning strategies make SRS
apps irrelevant you might remember that
earlier I mentioned that I do not use
Anki at all you might also remember that
after introducing the concept of space
repetition I mentioned that I'm a huge
fan of the concept and that I use it all
the time to learn languages so what
gives how is it possible to gain all of
the benefits of space repetition without
also using a program like Anki and all
of the drawbacks that come with it it is
surprisingly not at all that difficult
thinking back to emmingham's work on
Space repetition and the forgetting
curve the main idea revolves around the
benefits of getting repeated exposure to
a piece of information over a long
period of time though software like Anki
optimizes exactly when you do your
review there's not much benefit lost
from just making sure you spread out
your repetitions of a single piece of
learning content over the course of a
week or even a month by reviewing
regularly and giving yourself time to
forget between reviews you can Leverage
The Power of space repetition without
any of the maintenance that comes with
creating an Anki deck and without
getting sucked into the endless cycle of
adding cars and declining to review them
this is exactly how I structure my
bi-directional translation method which
is the method I follow to learn new
languages all the time I take a short
piece of content learn it deeply and
then review it in a variety of ways over
the course of a single week
here's a short breakdown of how the
whole thing works
on day one I read the content and listen
to the audio using the translation in my
mother tongue to try to understand the
text as deeply as possible
on day two I analyze the phonetic
patterns of the text the pronunciation
intonation and War stress on day three
I'll review the content in a brand new
way usually
um through just listening to the audio
just reading the text or something else
entirely on day four I take the target
language version of the text and make a
personalized translation of it in my own
native language
on day five I take my native language
translation from the previous day and
try to verbally translate it back into
my target language and on day six I
complete the cycle by taking my native
language translation and re-translating
it in writing back into the original
language then I make note of any errors
forgotten words or mistranslations the
cycle of taking a piece of language
content and processing it in various
ways is incredibly powerful and a lot
more fun than just sitting in front of
my computer creating digital flashcards
every day and it's something you should
definitely try if you get a chance
all right those are all of the reasons
why I do not use Anki and why I believe
you should not either there are much
better ways which I'll explore in even
more detail in a future video for now
let's recap the five reasons I believe
you should not use Anki to learn
vocabulary in a foreign language because
one making flash cards wastes learning
time two adding new cards can become an
addiction three reviewing old cards can
become a chore four flashcards take
language out of context and last but not
least five brain friendly learning
strategies make SRS apps irrelevant if
you want to take a deeper dive into my
anki-free strategies for space
repetition definitely check out the
courses it might become a master
language learner series both of which
use these strategies to full effect I've
got a beginner course about my
aforementioned bi-directional
translation method and an intermediate
course about overcoming the intermediate
Plateau as usual I left a link in the
description box and in the comment
pinned on top in the comments section
that's all for now thanks for watching
and as always happy language learning